[Music]
we've come to Cali an area inside Peru's
Amazon rainforest
that's been badly hit by deforestation
Hobart jamarius
is on his way to visit an indigenous
community they can only be reached by
boat
Kim arias heads up the Federation of
Native communities in this part of Peru
he grew up in a village here but he
doesn't come back often as it's become
too dangerous I received a lot of death
threats they left a message in my house
saying if I opposed their activities
again they'd better not see me in the
village
I believe I'm in great danger he opposes
the large-scale deforestation in his
region and that has earned him some
powerful enemies he never comes here
alone now this time he's with staff from
the organization Poetica the Peruvian
arm of transparency international they
visit santa clara de uchunya residents
here have come under pressure from
companies looking to set up cocoa and
palm oil plantations the village chief
calls everyone to a meeting to discuss
the latest developments they're taking
legal action to try to stop new palm oil
plantations opening nearby we never
thought that we would have such problems
with transnational companies on the
other side of the river large areas of
forest have already been stripped and
replaced with oil palms no one has
access to the area
we couldn't even film with a drone as
soon as we got near the plantation the
signal was disrupted village life has
changed in the past residents lived from
fishing and hunting
now all the large animals have
disappeared and there are fewer birds -
instead they've had an invasion of
mosquitos more than ever before their
traditional way of life has become
impossible we live from the land from
hunting fishing from the resources that
the jungle has to offer and indigenous
people without land just doesn't make
any sense
now the village wants to have 20,000
hectares turned into legally protected
ancestral territory but the initiative
has earned them death threats the danger
is very real just a few months ago six
farmers were found shot to death so far
no one has been held accountable for
their murders but how do these large
corporations get their hands on
thousands of hectares of land seemingly
overnight the anti-corruption group Pro
Etica has examined the land deals and
documented their findings
now staff from Poetica have come to
inform local residents we wanted to
highlight one thing namely the
connection between deforestation the
illegal trade in land and corruption
among local officials there are long
been rumors about this but there wasn't
enough evidence to be able to say
definitively yes it's true they gathered
all the available documents and carried
out numerous interviews many of the
deals reached in this region are linked
to Czech entrepreneur dennis melka he is
now being investigated by state
prosecutors the Melkor group companies
have stripped 13,000 hectares of
rainforest to make way for palm oil and
cocoa plantations they were helped by
corrupt local politicians who
invalidated existing land rights
effectively taking the land from its
owners we've come to Pucallpa the
capital of the region where we're
meeting two farmers they agreed to speak
to us in the protected environment of a
hotel in 2014 regional authorities
appropriated their land now there are
oil palms growing on it when I went to
the police about it there was suddenly
an attack they were trying to kill me
despite the intimidation tactics the
legal proceedings are continuing the
authorities have visited the land but
there's been no progress the farmers are
now hoping for outside help the order
we're still hoping that things will
improve international organizations will
get involved conservation groups who
will be able to do something the farmers
have lost faith in their own state and
local government
magalie Avila is heading to the regional
directors office which is responsible
for awarding land rights police are
following up on over a hundred
complaints against the official the
atmosphere is tense the director has the
entire conversation recorded he insists
that he has stayed within the law I
always say and this is a statement of
faith because I'm a Christian only the
truth will set me free nothing else
Magali addresses the demands of the
indigenous people for more land the
director says there are enough protected
areas and the remaining land needs to be
turned to profit when you say these
areas are poor that's clearly
contradicting your argument yes they are
poor that's why we need to find new ways
of developing them but the money made by
the palm oil plantations does not
benefit local indigenous communities
back to Santa Clara at Joe junior
village elders tell us that a few hours
after we left armed men were sent out to
patrol the edge of the village
yet another form of intimidation local
residents will need to keep up their
fight if they are to preserve their way
of life in future
you